more than 300 people had gathered here
for prayers
suicide bomber moved to the front and
detonated explosives that he'd concealed
in his vest
Down the Walls of the mosque in a
neighborhood called police lines killing
dozens in the blast
many others lost their lives when the
roof came down an unknown number are
still trapped in the rubble
that's the worst attack in Pakistan in
months taking place within a heavily
guarded area in peshawa key government
Ministries are located nearby
and it was also effective the
authorities say more than 170 sustained
injuries
the Imam started prayers and a huge
blast happened said this police officer
the roof and wall started collapsing on
us with thanks to God I survived
members of the police have been targeted
in recent attacks and the Pakistani
Taliban has claimed responsibility the
groups seek stricter enforcement of
Islamic laws
the country's prime minister Shahbaz
Sharif seen here visiting victims of the
Blast has vowed Stern action
[Music]
but in a country beset by a multitude of
challenges he may be unable to deliver
it John Sparks Sky News